and so today and for the remainder of
the week the theme is going to be the
cell division cycle and so we're gonna
really talk about the cell division
cycle in every lecture this week with
the penultimate lecture talking about
how this regulation of the cell
divisions cell cycle results in a
pathological condition known as cancer
okay so here is now a cell going through
the cell division cycle it's entered
into mitosis right now and these guys
here are the chromosomes of the cell and
you're going to see them line up at the
metaphase plate and eventually they'll
be segregated to the two poles of the
cell and then the cell will divide along
its equator okay so I thought we could
start today by just thinking about what
has to happen in a cell during the cell
division cycle what has to happen during
this during this process in order for
the cell to replicate
yes Malik or Myles
[Music]
mmm-hmm so so Myles suggested the
organelles have to be duplicated such
that the daughter cells can inherit
those organelles and that's correct what
else has to happen
anything else have to be duplicated
Stephen the the DNA the nuclear DNA the
chromosomes have to be duplicated so the
chromosomes have to be duplicated
duplicated what else has to happen every
cell cycle
what would happen to the size of the
cell that just when it divides yeah dude
oh what's that so who knows suggesting
that the cell has to grow right because
if if the cell didn't grow then cell
division would make smaller and smaller
and smaller cells and so another thing
the cell has to do during the cell cycle
at some point it has to grow in size
okay and what's the final point of the
cell cycle what happens which kind of
like the goal of the cell cycle yes
Steven
time to go mitosis and so the cell has
to physically divide right the
chromosomes have to be segregated and
the cell has to physically divide okay
and go so you can you can think of the
cell cycle as the goal of getting all
these events to happen is to get one
cell to become two cells so you need
chromosome segregation and you want an
equal segregation of genetic material
into two daughter cells after the cell
divides okay so today we're gonna unpack
the mechanisms that allow a cell to do
many of these things and how its
regulated and one thing to think about
is what what is going to determine
whether or not a cell enters the cell
division cycle and undergoes a division
what do you think are some things that
cells would care about if you're if it's
trying to decide whether or not to
divide
so one thing the cells gonna care about
in a multicellular setting is whether
it's getting appropriate communications
from other cells that are telling it to
divide and remember professor Imperioli
told you about signaling in one example
was receptor tyrosine kinase signaling
and this is just a diagram showing you
the Rass map kinase pathway and one of
the effects of this signaling pathway is
to promote cells to enter the cell
division cycle and in order to divide
okay so this is in a multicellular
organism the signaling is important for
unicellular organism cells might care
about whether or not there are nutrients
present or whether or not the cell is of
the right size okay so cells have to
make the decision I'm gonna focus mainly
on cell communication and how that might
change the cell physiology and I want to
start by just giving you a little bit of
an overview of the cell division cycle
so there are four distinct phases of the
cell division cycle and I split them
into two classes there are phases where
things physically happen to the cell and
those are S phase and M phase and so
during S phase S phase stands for DNA
synthesis and it's during S phase when
the nuclear DNA is replicated okay and
so for each of that action phases if you
will there's some sort of machinery
that's involved in changing the cell in
the case of S phase that would be DNA
polymerase and HeLa cases that mediate
the replication so HeLa cases DNA
polymerase and you remember from early
in the semester when we talked about DNA
replication all of the proteins that are
involved in replicating a chromosome
okay
the other phase where something really
physical happens is M phase which is
mitosis
and during mphase this is when the
sister chromatids of each chromosome are
separated to the daughter cells okay so
this is when chromosome segregation
happens and again during this phase
there has to be some sort of machine
that gets activated at this phase of the
cell cycle in order to this in this case
physically separate the chromosomes from
each other and that machine in M phase
is the mitotic spindle which you'll
recall is a machine that is consists of
microtubules so these are microtubules
and in each cell cycle these events have
to happen but they have to happen in
order right you need DNA synthesis
before you segregate the chromosomes
right so there there has to be an order
to this and so there is a so these other
phases are called gap phases and there
are two of them g1 and g2 and events
happen during these gap phases to help
to ensure that things happen in the
right order and so in g1 the cell has to
decide whether or not to enter into the
cell cycle so some things to consider
here the one that I mentioned before is
whether or not there are growth signals
present
okay so for a metazoan cell it's
important that the cell doesn't just
divide without any regard to what's
going on in the surroundings there needs
to be a communication between cells such
that there's a proper balance of cell
division in a tissue for specific cell
types okay so this is this g1 phase this
is when the cell if the cell goes from G
1 to s this is when the cell commits to
the cell cycle so G 1 to s this is the
time when the cell commits to going
through the entire cell cycle okay so if
the cell passes this G 1 to s transition
then the cell is committed to going
through the entire cell cycle okay the
other phase this G 2 phase ensures this
type of quality control that happens it
has to ensure that the DNA is replicated
before the cell moves on to mitosis okay
so you can think of G 2 as a phase where
there's a quality control mechanism and
the cell cares about whether or not its
DNA is replicated or not
okay so now I want to tell you basically
the answer as to how this system works
in a eukaryotic cell and this system
requires a level of control and it
requires a control system and what this
control system does is to ensure that
these different events that happen
during a cell cycle occur in the right
order okay so this control system is
going to ensure a proper order and there
are two main components to this control
system the first is called cyclin
dependent kinase or cdk and so cyclin
dependent kinase is a kinase so it can
post-translationally modify other
proteins by adding a phosphate group to
them and so it's through that mechanism
that cyclin dependent kinase can modify
events and control when they happen in
the cell cycle okay and the other key
component of the system is a protein
called cyclin and what cyclin is is it's
the regulatory subunit of the cdk so
this is the regulatory subunit of cdk
and so without the cyclin the
cyclin-dependent kinase is inactive okay
so the cdk needs to cyclin to have
activity so cyclones increase the
activity or activate cdk okay but there
are different flavors of cyclones there
are actually many different cyclones at
least four classes of cyclones and these
cyclones appear at different phases of
the cell cycle and then go away okay so
the Cyclones oscillate that's why
they're called cyclones because they
come on and off and depending on which
cyclin is present determines what cdk is
going to phosphorylate okay so these
cyclones also determine substrate
specificity of the kinase so this is
going to determine which cyclin
deprotonate EK phosphorylates so i've
outlined three classes of Cyclones here
here's a g1 s cyclin in complex of cdk
and then here's a s cyclin complex with
c DK in red and so what do you think the
s cyclin CDK is going to phosphorylate
what kind of protein and you would have
a guess miles
yes exactly you're actually exactly
right it's gonna phosphorylate and
activate things that are involved in DNA
replication and miles is right helicase
is one of the proteins that gets
phosphorylated by s cyclin CDK and then
similarly m cyclin CDK which is appears
here in blue during mitosis M cyclin CDK
is going to phosphorylate proteins that
are involved in forming the mitotic
spindle so that induces cell cycle
events that happen specifically during
mitosis okay so you all see it depends
which cyclin is present that determines
what cell cycle events are happening at
a given time and therefore it's
important that we understand how these
Cyclones appear at distinct cell cycle
phases and whether or not that's the
mechanism for the oscillation yes miles
[Music]
some organisms employ motors such that
organelles are physically sort of put in
daughter cells um but I think often it's
just random right if you dissolve the
organelle and it becomes like kind of
like a bunch of different vesicles then
if you just split in half there's a high
probability that each daughter cell will
get parts of the organelle okay so
organelles can change their morphology
during the division process in such a
way that they're able to be inherited by
both daughter cells okay that's an
excellent question so it's the Cyclones
that really determine what's happening
and I just wanted to point out here that
one of the main transcriptional targets
of RTK signaling is this g1 cyclin
it's the signaling pathways that lead to
the increase in g1 cyclin
start the cell on this process of
entering into the cell cycle okay so you
get these cyclones getting synthesized
and this cyclones appear in a defined
order okay so there are different
cyclones but they appear relative to
each other in a stereotypical order so
they appear in order and it's that order
of the cyclin that defines which cell
cycle events happen at what time in a
Cell okay now I want to tell you a
little bit about how the machinery
that's involved in the control of the
cell cycle was discovered and I'm gonna
start with by telling you a little bit
about budding yeast and by showing you
how this was discovered it'll give you a
sense as to how this system controls the
cell division cycle you'll recall that
budding yeast can exist as a haploid
cell in addition to existing as a
diploid cell so there's a haploid
diploid life cycle also one nice feature
of budding yeast for this particular
question is that you can infer the cell
cycle morphology of the yeast just by
looking at its morphology so budding
yeast divides by budding and the size of
the bud indicates what cell cycle phase
the cell is in okay so you can infer
cell cycle phase
by morphology of the ESL okay so for
example if we look up here here's an
unbuttoned G cell that's probably in g1
here's a yeast cell with a little teeny
bud on it that's probably an S phase
next to it over here is one that's a
slightly bigger bud and here's one with
an even bigger bud and that one might be
in g2 phase okay so because this bud
grows in size over the course of the
cell cycle you can just look at a yeast
cell and infer what the cell cycle phase
is okay so I'm going to tell you about a
genetic screen that was done to look for
mutants that were defective in the cell
division cycle and these are known as
cell division cycle or CDC mutants now
what type of yeast cell haploid or
diploid might you want to screen mutants
with what would be the advantages of
either one or the other
yeah Natalie
[Music]
yes so what Natalie suggested is to
start with the haploid mutants because
there's only one copy of each gene such
that if you hit it now you no longer
have a functional copy of that gene if
you started with a diploid cell you'd
have two copies of the gene and you'd
have to have two mutations both
happening in the same gene which would
be a rare event okay so it's better to
start with a haploid in this case now
what's the problem if you mutate a gene
that's involved in the cell cycle what's
going to be the phenotype the immediate
visible phenotype it could be alive or
dead carmen it's gonna be dead right and
it's hard to work with an organism
that's dead okay so what was done is to
look for a particular type of mutant
which is known as a
temperature-sensitive mutant and a
temperature-sensitive mutant is a mutant
where the cell or organism is alive and
well at one temperature but dead at
another temperature okay
and so the screen basically involved
taking yeast
here's yeast growing in a test-tube and
this is now haploid yeast and you can
treat that yeast with a mutagen
it doesn't matter what just something
that will induce mutations at a high
rate in these yeast cells and you can
take these cells and plate them on media
where individual cells will grow into
colonies okay and this is if you grow it
at 22 degrees C for yeast this is the
most moderate temperature you can choose
so this is what's known as the
permissive temperature
okay but you can also take this plate of
yeast colonies and duplicate it and grow
it at another temperature and you might
get something that looks like this
where you see this colony grew at 22
degrees but at 37 degrees C it did not
grow and that would suggest that then
this has a temperature temperature
sensitive mutant and this temperature of
37 degrees is known as the restrictive
temperature okay so that would identify
a temperature sensitive mutant now as
every temperature sensitive mutant that
you identify is that going to be a cell
division cycle mutant miles you're
shaking your head no why is that can you
explain your logic
mm-hmm exactly so miles is suggesting
that if you if you just mutated any old
gene that was involved in viability for
this yeast and it unfolded at 37 degrees
because you sort of made a mutation that
made it unstable then you would identify
that as a temperature-sensitive mutant
so what would be a good criteria I guess
that we could use to select just the
mutants that are affecting the cell
division cycle might there be a way for
us to do that I guess I'm asking can we
narrow down the phenotype right
temperature sensitivity could be by
affecting any process in yeast is there
a way we can gear it towards the cell
division cycle Diana
all right very good so a Diana
suggesting is that we looked for a
phenotype and she's guessed at the
phenotype if this gene is involved in
sort of mediating a change from one cell
cycle to phase to another that if you
mutate that you'd have yeast it's all
stuck in one phase okay and that's
indeed the phenotype that was screened
for okay and so if you just take a
random population of yeast that's
dividing you'll get you'll see cells
that are unbuttered small butted
slightly bigger butted and if you count
the number of cells what you'll see is
that most of your cells are unbuttered
some are small blooded and a larger
percentage are large blooded and this
just reflects the relative amount of
time that yeast is in each of these
phases of the cell cycle
so yeast spends most of its time in g1
therefore if you look at a random
population of yeast you'll see most of
the cells will be in the unwanted State
okay so this is for wild-type normal
East now what was identified is a cell
division cycle mutant CVC 28 which at
the restrictive temperature causes a
trainwreck at a specific phase of the
cell cycle okay so all of the cells now
are stuck in the unbuttered state and so
this suggests that these cells when they
are shifted to the restrictive
temperature are still able to move
through the cell cycle but once they get
to this phase they get stuck okay so
here there's a cell cycle arrest at g1
and they confirmed it was g1 by
measuring the DNA content and by
measuring the DNA content they're able
to show that that this these cells did
not duplicate their DNA so they didn't
even start to undergo S phase they were
stuck in g1
okay okay so that suggests that this C
dc28 gene is required for cells to go
from g1 to s okay so the wild type C
dc28 gene is required for this
transition from g1 into the S phase and
it turns out that this yeast CDC 28 gene
is the one yeast cyclin dependent kinase
okay so this was sort of the defining
mutant for cyclin dependent kinase and
you'll recall earlier in this semester
when we talked about molecular biology
that we talked about work done by paul
nurse who use functional complementation
to clone the human cyclin dependent
kinase by transforming DNA into a
different yeast fission yeast but again
that rescued the cell cycle arrest and
that's how the human cyclin dependent
kinase was discovered okay and I just
wanted to point out here that the work
i'm telling you about was awarded the
Nobel Prize in Physiology and medicine
in 2001 and it was awarded to Lila and
Hartwell Tim hunt and Sir Paul nurse
Leland Hartwell did the screen that I
just told you about there and identified
CDC 28 and we already talked about Paul
nurse earlier in the semester Tim hunt
worked on clams and sea urchins and
identified cyclin so this was the work
that identified the regulatory machinery
of the cell cycle and they sort of show
that this worked in a number of
different organisms and they showed that
it was evolutionarily conserved from
yeast all the way to humans okay so this
is a conserved mechanism
okay so so there's a mechanism that
actively governs the transition from g1
to s and I'll point out this is this
transition is known as start in yeast
and it's called the restriction point in
mammalian cells it's kind of the point
of no-return in the cell cycle but the
cell cycle doesn't just blindly charge
through the rest of the way and there
are certain quality control mechanisms
that are in place to ensure that things
happen in the proper order
and that the quality of events happening
is good before the cell moves on to the
next stage and so I'm gonna define a
concept called a checkpoint and the
checkpoint is a type of quality control
mechanism and checkpoints operate in
this cell cycle to ensure that one event
doesn't proceed until the doesn't occur
till the preceding event happens
correctly okay so this ensures proper
order of events and ensures that events
happen correctly before the next
subsequent event has to occur okay so
one example of this is if you just
consider s phase and M phase DNA
replication has to finish before the
cell starts segregating chromosomes
otherwise there's going to be
catastrophic consequences such as
possibly creating a cancer cell okay so
one example of a checkpoint is called
the DNA damage checkpoint and what the
DNA damage checkpoint does is it looks
to see if there's DNA damage or if the
DNA is still replicating
and if either of these cases is present
in a cell then it sends a signal and
that signal in order to influence the
cell division cycle has to interface
with the cyclin CDK control machinery
okay so this signal will then inhibit
cyclin CDK and cyclin CDK governs two
major transitions in the cell cycle so
there are two major what I'll call
transition points
there's the g1 to s which I just
outlined over there which is called
start
so there's g1 to s but there's also g2
to em okay so these basically the
transition out of the gap phases those
are the key transition points that can
be regulated by the cell to either slow
things down to halt the transition or
just go right through okay so let me
tell you about an experiment that
defined the functionality of one of
these check out the DNA damage
checkpoint and I'm going to tell you
about work done by Weinert and Weiland
Hartwell and it was published in 1988
and they were interested in what's what
the nature and the function of these
checkpoints was and so you can take
budding yeast and you can damage its DNA
by radiating the cells with x-rays and
if you are radiate the cell with x-rays
in a wild-type normal yeast so in the
normal yeast
that's not mutant then this damages the
DNA and the cell stays in g2 okay so it
stays in g2
okay and there's a delay okay so here
what I'm drawing is a g2 delay so the
cell spends an abnormally longer time in
g2 than it normally would if you didn't
damage its DNA all right and then over
time it will continue in the cell cycle
and enter into the next cell cycle and
what's what's interesting about this is
that these cells live okay so one
interpretation from this result is you
damage the cell's DNA it delayed the
cell cycle in g2 so it didn't rush right
into chromosome segregation and that
allowed the cell time to repair its DNA
and that enabled the cell daughters to
live okay so that's an interpretation
now part of the evidence for that
interpretation is that Hartwell and
Weinert discovered a mutant called rad 9
so the rad 9 mutant and rad 9 stands for
radiation sensitive this is a radiation
sensitive mutant and this particular
radiation sensitive mutant disrupted the
delay so it disrupted the checkpoint
here so what happens in a rad 9 mutant
is again you are radiate cells with
x-rays the cell goes from S phase to g2
but this time there's no delay so it
goes from G to the poor yeast charges
unsuspectingly into mitosis with damaged
DNA and divides but in this case there's
a high level of death and this the
resulting progeny so that here you have
death okay so rad 9 then is a gene that
is involved in promoting the cell cycle
delay such that the yeast cell has time
to repair its DNA and if you remove that
delay so here there's no delay
if you disrupt this delay which defines
the checkpoint process right the
checkpoint is a process whereby if
there's DNA damage you delay the cell
cycle such that the cell has time to
repair it if you don't have that it has
bad consequences for the yeast cell and
results in yeast cells undergoing
premature mitosis before they've had a
chance to repair the DNA all right one
thing you might be wondering is what
causes these cyclin proteins to
oscillate and so the last point I want
to make is I want to tell you about the
mechanism that allows these protein
oscillations and it involves a mechanism
that's going to be new for you at least
from the context of this class it's a
mechanism that's regulated proteolysis
okay so there's a regulated degradation
of the cyclin proteins that allows them
to go up and then down okay so if we
consider just one part of the cell cycle
well if I plot the concentration of
cyclin and we look at M cyclin from G 2
to M phase so this here is a time axis
the M cyclin goes up and M phase and
then it drops precipitously during
mitosis specifically at the metaphase
anaphase transition okay so this is for
the mitotic cyclin-cdk nin cyclin levels
is due to regulated proteolysis okay and
it involves a mechanism that you were
briefly introduced to by Professor
Imperiali
because it involves
small protein known as ubiquitin and
what ubiquitin is is it's a small 76
amino acid protein so it's a 76 amino
acid protein but this protein can get
attached to other proteins so it's a
post translational modification okay so
ubiquitin which I'll abbreviate UB
ubiquitin is attached to lysines on a
target protein and that's the attachment
of ubiquitin x' to lysines of a protein
has important consequences and what
Professor Imperiali told you about is
when this happens in the case of protein
misfolding but this ubiquitination of
proteins also occurs two proteins that
are not denatured or mis folded and it's
a way of regulating protein levels in
the cell okay so that what happens is
I'll show you a complicated diagram of
what happens but I'm really going to
focus on this step right here there's a
series of steps that need are needed to
get ubiquitin to get attached to the
target protein I'm going to ignore
pretty much all of that but there's an
e-2 enzyme that becomes conjugated with
ubiquitin and then that is able the
ubiquitin is able to be transferred to a
target protein and rather than make this
generic I'll let you know the target
protein is going to be cyclin so we'll
just say cyclin and so there's an enzyme
that transfers the ubiquitin from the e
2 to the cyclin
okay and it's poly ubiquitinated meaning
there's a chain of ubiquitin added to
the cyclin and it's carried out by a
particular type of enzyme known as an e3
ubiquitin ligase and there are hundreds
of these ubiquitin ligases in humans and
different III ubiquitin ligases confer
different specificities so they target
different proteins okay
so different III target different
proteins and so this is where the
specificity comes from okay so when it
when a protein in the cell miss folded
or not is poly ubiquitinated like this
this is the this is a garbage tag on
that protein okay so you can think of
poly ubiquitin as a garbage tag and once
it's poly Bickerton aidid it's sent to
the proteasome which professor Imperiali
showed you and this is the structure
that degrades proteins okay so so if the
protein is targeted for degradation by
putting this tag on it it's going to be
rapidly protea lies in the cytoplasm of
the cell
alright now I want to show you some
experiments that provided the first
evidence that this regulated proteolysis
is what sort of causes the cyclin to
oscillate okay and it's going to involve
a new model organism is there anyone
here that has rented a phobia okay we
all like frogs okay
so this model organism is Xenakis Lavis
or the African clawed frog and I want to
thank my colleague at UMass Amherst Tom
Morasca
who provided these slides of frogs for
me so what's great about these frogs
well other than they're being very cute
is that they lay a ton of eggs and the
eggs are huge okay so
here's a mom a mom frog and then you see
all these circular things all around the
Frog are the eggs okay so they're about
one millimeter in size they're huge you
can collect these eggs put them in a
test tube and you can see all these eggs
that you have in this test tube and then
you can spin the test tube and by
spinning the test tube in a centrifuge
you crush the eggs okay
and so that results in this middle layer
here which is cytoplasm okay and you can
remove it with a syringe and what you
end up with is a concentrated
cytoplasmic extract so that's all
cytoplasm okay so that's a lot of
cytoplasm okay so for the Senecas system
this system allows you to get this
highly concentrated because it's not
diluted it's the same concentration as
cytoplasm almost cytoplasmic
extract which is known as Zen abyss egg
extract okay and what's amazing about
this egg extract is it can go through
the cell cycle even though it's not in a
cell
okay so you can get this extract to
essentially simulate the cell cycle okay
so you have to mimic fertilization
because that's when cell divisions start
to happen and in the normal frog embryo
but once you do this then you you mimic
the fertilization process by adding
calcium and then you'll see this extract
go through the cell cycle and you can
see it by looking at the morphology of
different structures in the extract so
this is a nucleus that has assembled an
extract around some DNA that was added
hey DNA replication can happen in this
nucleus other events that happen in
inter phase of the cell cycle also
happen in this extract and if you wait
then it will go into mitosis and you'll
start to see mitotic spindles assembling
in the extract okay so it's important
about this this is totally in vitro okay
so this is an in vitro system there are
no cells but you're able to see the
extract go through the cell cycle okay
and if you were able to look at cyclin
like m cyclin you'd see that M cyclin
levels go up and then down and up and
down they oscillate just like they would
in a cell okay and this is just a
diagram showing you that here where
mitotic cyclin-cdk activity for M cyclin
CDK is in purple so you see it goes up
goes and then the cell enters mitosis
early mitosis is in blue late mitosis is
in orange
so you see mitosis happens when m cyclin
is high just like it does in a cell and
then it degrades and then it repeats
okay so this is all outside of a cell
you're just looking in a test tube and
you can recreate the cell cycle
now this because this is a biochemical
system allowed these researchers in this
case the researchers who did this
experiment where Andrew Murray and Marc
Kirschner at Harvard and what they did
was to test the role of various
components in this oscillation the first
experiment they did was to rnase treat
the extract to get rid of all the mRNA
and if you degrade all the mRNA in this
extract you no longer get the cycling
you no longer get the cell cycle so this
shows you mRNA is important or necessary
but you don't know which mRNA right one
hypothesis might be that you need the
mRNA from M cyclin in order to produce
cyclin every cell cycle and that was
their hypothesis so what they did to
test that was to degrade all the mRNA
inactivate the RNAs and then
add back the mRNA to one gene the
mitotic cyclin-cdk n is sufficient to
restore the oscillation of the mitotic
cycle okay now the last experiment which
I think is the most important shows you
the mechanism by which the cyclin is
going because they added in instead of
adding back the wild-type mitotic
cyclin-cdk ball by this e3 ubiquitin
ligase mechanism okay so if they add
back a cyclin mutant and this mutant has
a deletion in the part of the protein
called the destruction box and this is
essentially the part of the protein that
is recognized by the e3 ubiquitin ligase
okay so the psyche the destruction box
mutant basically blocks this such that
cyclin is no longer poly ubiquitinated
and it can't be targeted for proteolysis
okay and then this happened in this case
what happens is cyclin levels increase
and then they stay high and there's no
cycle okay so when you have this cyclin
mutants with the destruction box deleted
such that it's non degraded it's not not
degraded you get a cell cycle arrest and
because this is M cycle I am cycling the
cell arrests in mitosis you get a
mitotic arrest mitotic arrest okay any
questions about this mechanism of
proteolytic degradation you all see how
this yes
Malik
what is it physically doing it's
basically stuck with like a mitotic
spindle and it's not segregating the
chromosomes yeah so it hasn't gone
through mitosis it's stuck in a specific
phase of mitosis in this case it's stuck
in and basically a metaphase like state
one last point I want to make about this
is that the mRNA for M cyclin is just
constant it's always present so this is
constant you have constant mRNA cdk is
constant it's the cyclin protein that's
going up and down and it's going up and
down because of this regulated
proteolysis okay great on Wednesday
we'll talk about stem cells and we'll
talk about guts
you